the tools for
thinking that are developed and proven
and and refined in in the sciences and
in the other academic disciplines have
sort of filtered down into popular
culture and become part of the ambient
culture that you learn independently of
school and that this is why people are
actually thinking better they're
actually better problem solvers they see
patterns better and so forth in any case
it's it's a hypothesis that uh hasn't
been disproven and and has a good chance
of being the right uh the right answer
to that question and the reason I
mention it is because if you ask me wait
a minute are you saying that these
Thinking Tools actually make us smarter
I'm saying yes yes they
do um
so what are some Thinking Tools well par
excelance The Thinking Tools are words
can't do much thinking without
words and uh I'm reminded of a famous
line of geras uh when ideas fail words
come in very
handy he really did say that and uh uh
when you think about it you realize what
wisdom is there when the when the
thinking gets really hard you can often
use words as a certain sort of
prosthetic device or crutch to help you
over some difficult
stretches numbers obviously are Thinking
Tools diagrams
Maps uh methods of all kinds from
finding the average to long division to
cost benefit analysis you name it notice
that these are all quite abstract things
they their
techniques for handling information in
your head rather than tools that you
plug in or need a power source for um
then there's intuition pumps I coined
the term way back in 1980 or 81 uh in
order to talk about John
stl's famous or notorious Chinese room
thought experiment I said it's an
intuition pump and because I was on that
occasion criticizing a lot of people
thought that I meant the term intuition
pump
pejoratively no I didn't actually and
I've since explained that I think
intuition pumps at their best are
wonderful they are the best
philosophical Thinking Tools there are
and they always have been if you look at
the history of
philosophy Plato's
Cave Socrates teaching the slave boy
geometry they carts evil demon hobb's
state of nature these are the these are
the great Melodies of philosophy that
you remember long after you've forgotten
the details of the arguments so
philosophers have always used intuition
pumps little
stories uh scenarios vignettes and
they're not typically formal
arguments they're little
stories it's not like doing sums when
you get to the end you've got the answer
very few intuition pumps are like that
they're much more like eso's fables you
get the end there's a little moral you
hm interesting you'd put it that way and
and if it really works you pound your
fist on the table and say it's got to be
that way that's the intuition that's
been
pumped now they're persuaders in other
words as somebody wrote me the other day
saying well I've I've I've looked at
your your book now and I think what
you're really talking about in every
case you're talking about social
thinking you're talking about persuading
others it's it's very much uh
interpersonal uh and I wrote back said
yes and in fact I should have stressed
that more all really serious thinking is
interpersonal I think I think that's in
fact one of the keys to how we think is
by challenging each other with our
ideas lovely case in point Andrew
WS proved fairmont's Last Theorem a few
years back but nobody could be sure even
WS himself couldn't be sure he'd done it
until his peers his colleagues in
mathematics who would dearly love to
have the honor of having proved
fairmont's Last Theorem themselves until
they had signed off and said darn it yes
he's got it
congratulations this
competitive opponent process between
people is actually one of the key
intuition pumps or the key Thinking
Tools all on its own and so this is a
book very much about how to persuade
others and yourself about difficult
matters they're also tools of Discovery
by exploring these vignettes you encount
you encounter either problems that you
hadn't anticipated or sometimes
opportunities that you would not
otherwise notice and they hold our
attention you you can just refer back to
them and at least they give you a a a
focus on a topic that's very useful
now some
fields of academic inquiry have lots of
fixed points just immovable Bedrock
philosophy I think has
none hardly a
one maybe the law of non-contradiction
according to
Aristotle what we have are candidates
for fix points we say in effect suppose
for the sake of argument we treat this
and this and this as fix points now what
follows from those three points
triangulate those see what kind of a
theory you can make of that see how the
questions look if we take those as fix
points so very often an intuition pump
is a is a wonderful fixer of a candidate
for a fix point and that's a very
valuable tool in
itself how powerful are these
tools they're this powerful they drove
what is one of the great
biological phenomena in the history of
Life on this
planet Paul mccre the late great green
engineer if you don't know who Paul
mccre is I'll probably be able to
identify him for you by drawing
attention to the fact that he's the one
who designed and built the gos gossamer
albatross
the the human powered airplane that flew
across the British
Channel um he pointed out that 10,000
years ago a twinkling in G in in
biological time at the very dawn of
Agriculture our species plus its
livestock and its
pets was a fraction of 1% of the by
weight if you like of the terrestrial
vertebrae
biomass a minor
primate what is it
today 10,000 years later any
guesses
99% 85 I hear any other
this you know that's not
true there are a few Bears out in the
woods but it's actually it's
98% most of that's
cattle but in 10,000 years our species
plus its domesticated animals have
completely transformed the
biosphere in a way that really hardly I
don't think any earlier Global event can
compete with that for the changes that
have been WR in just 10,000 years and
this is what this is what mccre says
about it over for billions of years on a
unique sphere chance has painted a thin
covering of life I love that image
chance has painted a thin covering of
Life complex improbable wonderful and
fragile suddenly we humans have grown in
population technology and intelligence
to a position of terrible power we now
wield the
paintbrush that's true and we have the
same genes that our ancestors 10,000
years ago had that our ancestors 100,000
years ago pretty much it's not
genetic it's Thinking Tools that have
made this all
possible which raises a chicken egg
problem did evolve tools make us
smarter or did we evolve to become smart
enough to make
tools and the answer as to all good
chicken egg problems is
yes
it's co-evolutionary it's a sort of
bootstrapping thing where we get a
little bit smarter smart enough to make
a few tools and then those tools make us
smarter still And So It Goes building
and building and
building my next book is going to be
about that
process so some simple tools from the
book uh everybody knows reductio
absurdum even if you don't know the name
it is that you might say it's the great
crowbar of thought it is the way you
budge people from their position by
taking their
premises saying well if we assume for
the sake of argument that your premises
are such and such look what I can do and
then you deduce logically from those
premises a contradiction something
absurd in fact we use this all the time
in in more more informally and don't
even notice it but it's really the same
thing I mean if you say um
if that's a bear then Bears have antlers
uh that's really a sort of reductio odd
absurdum
argument
um I mention it in part because I want
to point out that although we use
reductive aurum arguments in either
expanded or truncated form we also imply
them all the time using rhetorical
questions a rhetorical question whenever
you see one one of those questions that
isn't supposed to be answered
stop and think about it it's an implied
reductio the idea is ha you can't answer
this question it would be it's it's so
obvious that the that that the answer to
this question uh uh is so obvious that
uh I don't even have to mention what the
answer is everybody knows nudge
nudge well that means
that a good practice a habit to get into
is when you see one of those question
marks in a in a doc document a
rhetorical question try answering the
question and see if maybe it's not so
ridiculous after all uh in one of my
favorite Peanuts cartoon strips Charlie
Brown says something like well who's to
say what is right and what is wrong and
Lucy says I
will and try it you like it sometimes
you can really
bring a person up short by just
answering their their rhetorical
question then there's the surely
alarm I tell my students every time you
see the word surely a little bell should
Ring
Ding and you should pause hearing the
shirely alarm and you should look to see
if you have just found the weak point in
the
argument why well what follows the
surely is a sentence that the author
wants you to believe is putting forward
is
true it's not so obvious that it goes
without saying if it were it would go
without saying and here the author is
putting it
in but not bothering to argue for it
instead trying to get by on the cheap
with a little nudge a little
surely so if you have have a surely
alarm and this becomes just a a habit in
your mind this this will stand you in
good stead I've been inviting people to
send me now that they've installed a
surely alarm in their brain uh to tell
send me examples where they catch they
catch a surely marking a weak spot I I
did a little research on this I actually
went and string searched for surely in
several dozen actually more like 70 or
75 philosophy papers online
and found a couple of dozen shoreless
and checked them out and and about a
third of them were were I thought
clearly the weakest point in the case
being made in that in that article it
doesn't work all the time there a lot of
false alarms you can go ahead and use
the word surely every now and then but
if you hear the word surely you should
ding so just give it a little try
because surely if you I didn't hear if
sure surely if you get in the habit of
of whenever you hear the word surely a
little bell
rings practice surely ding thank
you now look what I've
done I've just downloaded an app to your
neck
toop in the same way that an app on your
on your smartphone adds to the
functionality of gives gives your
smartphone a new Talent a new capacity
it's like Google alert or something like
that you now have another little tool in
your kit that may very well alert you to
a weak spot in some argument that you're
otherwise impressed
with
okay computers are of course Thinking
Tools par excellence and I there's a lot
about computers in the book and I have
learned from many years experience that
a lot of people think they understand
how computers work and they don't really
and if they just understood a bit more
they would understand a lot more things
that can be easily understood with the
help of computers so there's there's an
interlude on computers including what
must be an eccentric first in a
tradebook there's actually a chapter
which teaches you how to program the
world's simplest computer a register
machine and there are even problem sets
with the answers at the back of the book
If you will spend a couple of hours with
that chapter you will understand
computers the way you never understood
them before but of course you're free to
pass over that if you really don't
care um how long by the way was a
philosopher uh who came up with the idea
of a register machine around the same
time little after girdle's famous uh
proof and touring coming up with the
Tory machine and the the Wong register
machine is is is computes everything
that's touring computable so it's a it's
a userfriendly
alternative to a touring machine if
you've ever tried to program a touring
machine you know it's hard it's very
counterintuitive but a register machine
is very easy to understand it's it's the
world's simplest computer and there are
some little exercises on
that now here's some Thinking Tools well
actually this picture I want to point
out this is a this picture is all by
itself a thinking to it draws attention
to a rather striking
comparison uh
and provokes reflection the one on the
left is an ash and hand axe the one on
the right I don't need to tell
you notice the asalan hand ax was used
in this form unchanged
without any noticeable improvements for
over a million
years weird really
strange the mouse in comparison has only
been around for a few
decades and is probably on the way
out the speed of
tool use and Improvement is picked up a
little
bit over biological
time here's another thinking tool all on
its own the comparison between these two
entities on the
left you see an Australian termite
Castle on the right you see gaudi's
famous Church in Barcelona the Sada
Familia they're strikingly similar in
appearance and actually in structure
even internally they're quite remarkably
similar so here are two artifacts made
by
animals
looking very similar and yet profoundly
different in both the the design and
construction the one on the left is
designed by darwinian
processes clueless mindless little
termites it's all local action there's
no there's no blueprint there's no
intelligent designer there's no no boss
there's no hierarchy it's bottomup
Construction in sort of every sense of
the word
whereas Gaudi is the very model of an
intelligent
designer
autocratic full of manifestos and
blueprints and orders ordering the
underlings around
uh now they're both
natural and one of the really
interesting questions is how do we
get in this on this planet how did we
get from termite Style design and
construction to Gaudi style design and
construction how did the second kind
evolve from the
first that's a very deep and interesting
question that's the one that I am now
devoting as much time as I can to and
will attack in the next
book
that